it's time for the launch in chrono scope
a television journal of the important
issues of the hour brought to you every
Monday Wednesday and Friday a
presentation of the lawn gene which nor
wats company maker of lon gene the
world's most honored watch and wit nor
distinguished companion to the world
honored lon gene good evening this is
frank night may I introduce our
co-editors for this edition of the lawn
gene chrono scope from the CBS
television news staff Larry loser and
Don Hollenbeck our distinguished guest
for this evening is the honorable Homer
Ferguson chairman of the Senate
Republican policy committee senator
Ferguson it's a fortunate news
coincidence that you should be here
tonight on our regularly scheduled
horoscope program and we've just seen in
her to President Truman's speech and I
know you can't ask for the whole
Republican Party but as a lawyer and as
the chairman of the Senate Republican
Committee do you think he made a good
case for himself tonight well I I
realized that the president tried to
make a case for himself the thing that
puzzles me more than anything else in
this whole matter that the president has
discussed is the fact that he leaves the
people draw the conclusion that he used
the Senate of the United States in order
to create a decoy as he calls it now so
that they could get certain amount of
evidence let me point to one place in
his address tonight where he said it was
originally planned that mr. white would
be elected to a managerial position in
the international monetary fund that of
managing director and then he goes on
and says that after the receipt of the
FBI report and the consultation with
members of the cabinet they decided to
change that
and make him only a member of the board
of directors that indicates that he knew
when it was sent to the United States
Senate that the Senate would be allowed
to act upon a man whose record is now
indicated by the FBI's files to be that
of one who should not be named now the
rules of the senator clear that the
President of the United States indicates
that they had confirmed these this man
in an afternoon and that he knew it
immediately following that under the law
he could have sent that name back to the
Senate and then a reconsideration could
have taken place because the rule says
that it's for two days they can make
such a reconsideration and it could have
been withdrawn now not one word has was
ever told to the Congress of the United
States is indicated by the president
well senator Ferguson didn't he say just
directly after that statement that an
intensive FBI investigation was in
progress at that tires but here's the
thing that surprises I think everybody
it was allowed to leak out as if FBI
director J Edgar Hoover had planned this
to use this man as a decoy now he
doesn't say one word about that in his
present talk tonight he doesn't combine
Hoover with any of his people that he
consulted he leaves that to the
imagination that an FBI was to
investigate now here's another thing
though that he'll say he does mention
Attorney General Tom Clark yeah they got
boy he doesn't mention see mr. Clark
refuses to come as a witness therefore
he names Tom Clark all right but what
I'm concerned about here tonight is the
fact that he doesn't name j edgar hoover
although it was leaked out that hoover
had a specific agreement on this matter
now
mr. I asked 10 question last Saturday
when I knew that mr. Truman was going to
speak and he hasn't answered those
questions would you care to say just
what some of those questions worsen I
want to see what they are one of them
was for instance if mr. Truman learned
in 1947 that white was disloyal and
fired him why did he continually refer
to the investigations conducted by the
Senate and the House Committee of those
espionage rings of which white was a
member as a red Harry the next question
which is all vital why did mr. Truman
write a letter dated april of 30th 1946
several months after he now says he saw
this report that branded this man as it
did saying this you will be able to
carry forward the work you so able he
began at bretton woods and you will have
increased opportunity to excerpt for the
exercise of your wide knowledge and
experts in a field which is of utmost
importance to world peace and security
if he knew that white was disloyal to
his country the South await the
president wasn't satisfied with writing
that letter he wrote another one when he
left the employ of the monetary fund and
here's what he said he said he the
president would feel free to call on
white for later assistance because quote
your background and abilities make you
peculiarly able to help us now I just
want to know why under these
circumstances the Senate of the United
States one of the bodies that the
president speaks about being an
independent branch of government was
allowed to do this to confirm this man
when this record was before the
President of the United States well you
don't think that he covers that in his
comment tonight that he was restricting
the duties of mr. white and that they
were doing this deliberately well the
collaboration of the FBI and if they
couldn't take the Senate into their
confidence or any senators or any Senate
leaders well I know of no one in the
Senate was taken into the confidence and
here here's the difficulty in this whole
case this is only an isolated incident I
want to know why mr. ko Frank cope was
placed in the same monetary fund and
when just recently a few months ago he
was called before the committee he
refused to testify as to whether or not
he was a communist whether he was
engaged in communist activities or
subversion and he was very similar in
his answers to what they accused white
of now how do they explain that why was
he allowed to remain in the monetary
fund all the time wasn't an aphorism do
you think this FBI director J Edgar
Hoover should now be called upon to
testify well he doesn't here's the queer
thing in this whole analysis tonight he
never once mentioned mr. Hoover's name
and as I said before he allowed it to
leak out that mr. Hoover was the man who
agreed to watch it now who was the
people that watched this man he doesn't
say the secretary of the Treasury well
the secretary of the Treasury changed
who was to watch this man as to whether
or not he was actually carrying out
these activities what does he say an FBI
investigation was in progress of mr.
white and hundreds of other persons and
he sews following an FBI report well he
says that the report was made yes and
that there wasn't enough evidence to
convict him but what I want to call the
people's attention to that no one in
that case before that grand jury was
indicted for espionage they only
indicted the 11 leaders for conspiring
to overthrow the government by force or
violence or teach the overthrow now I
come back to this case that when here
for instance in these subversive
activities committee of which I was a
member up until last January there is a
finding the conclusions on page 49 I
want to read them to the people tonight
because here was the Congress of the
United States trying to point out that
there were communists in government and
not one case did the president of the
United States or any of the executive
branch give us help to ferret them out
he called it a red herring when I was
working on the Remington case he
referred to that as he did to his case
and as a read Harry does he tell us
tonight that they had his in as a decoy
and that they were watching him he was
named in this report in 1946 and
remained in there until nineteen forty
seven but going to read this in general
the Communists who's until tainted our
government worked behind the scene
guiding research and preparing
memorandums of which the base basic
American policies were set writing
speeches for cabinet officers
influencing congressional investigations
drafting laws manipulating
administrative reorganizations all was
serving the interest of their Soviet
superiors despite the fact that the
Federal Bureau of Investigation and
other security agents had reported
extensive information about this
communist penetration little was done by
the executive branch to interrupt the
Soviet operations in their ascent in
government until congressional
committees brought forth the public
light the facts nine is the grand jury
indictment that you're eating now no I'm
reading the report of the Internal
Security which was signed by the
Republican members and Pat McCarran a
Democrat Jim Eastland a rip Democrat and
or indeed Johnson a Democrat now listen
what they say powerful groups
and individuals within the executive
branch were at work obstructing and
weakening the effect effort to eliminate
Soviet agents from positions in
government now of course you can you can
now criticize any disclosure of any
communists in government but let me say
that I honestly believe that the people
are entitled to the facts if there were
communist spies or agents in our
government the only way that you're
going to preserve this country of ours
is to let the people know and if the
people know it then they will be able to
cope with the situation now the site of
Ferguson tonight mr. Truman called
Attorney General brownell a man who was
using political demagoguery can you tell
us as chairman of the Republican policy
committee were there any political
reasons for the timing of mr. brownells
charges against mr. tomb well certainly
none that I knew all now let me say this
that it was a quarter after twelve on
the day that this speech was made in
Chicago before I knew it was going to be
made so as far as I was concerned I knew
of nothing and I know of nothing to this
day that was used in this timing was the
final question senator Ferguson may ask
you this we spent a lot of money abroad
now to build up American leadership do
you think that we're losing a great deal
of this prestige through these violent
partisan attacks abroad I mean well
let's look at mr. Truman's attack
tonight mr. Truman had a right to take
the radio and say what he thought I I go
back to when Ben Franklin said that we
had a republic if we could keep it and I
think the only way that we can keep our
republic is to debate these matters out
on the anvil of debate so that the
American public can decide these issues
and we can't watch 60 other nations to
determine what they may think I'm
satisfied that mr. Truman
didn't consider tonight what any other
nation would think as to what he was
saying about the present administration
thank you very much senator Homer
Ferguson has been a pleasure to have you
here tonight the opinions that you've
heard our speakers expressed tonight
have been entirely their own the
editorial board to this edition of the
lawn gene krona scope was Larry lesser
and Don Hollenbeck our distinguished
guest was the Honorable Homer Ferguson
chairman of the Senate Republican policy
committee